Yle Areena.
Esko Eläkeläinen, Helsingin maailmilta. Olen tässä ihmetellyt jo vuosikymmeniä, kun jopa tiedemiehet puhuvat kuun pimeästä puolesta.
Se on yhtä valoisa kuin tämä maahan näkyvä puoli. Jou'uden kuun aikana se on kirkas, vaikka pimeä puoli on maata vasta. Eikö olisi asiallisempaa puhua etupuoli, joka näkyy meille ja takapuoli, joka on poispäin. Pimeä puoli se ei ole.
Kuun meille näkymätön puoli. Sellaisestakin olen kuullut puhuttavan, mutta ei ole yhtä nopea eikä yhtä näppärä kuin juuri äsken ehdotettu. Kuun etu ja kuun takapuoli. Siitä tosin olen tyytyväinen, että noita nimiä ei käytetty, kun olin ala aste ikäinen opettaja. Jos olisi meidän luokalle puhunut kuun takapuolesta, niin siitä hirnumisesta ei olisi tullut loppua ehkä tähän päivään asti. Se on Kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä tervehdyssä.
Kuusta puheen ollen se ihmetyttää muuten yhtä soittajaa, kun ihminen on päässyt kuuhun ja kuun lähelle, mutta kestäviä siivousvälineitä ei osata valmistaa. Samalla tavalla ihmetystä aiheuttavat tällä viikolla muun muassa mahdolliset droonituhojen korvaukset ja rollaattorien rengaskoot. Viime viikolla eduskunnassa käytiin välikysymyskeskustelu köyhyydestä. Sen herättämät reaktiot eivät ihan kerenneet tuohon edelliseen jaksoon, mutta tähän kerjäänneet.
- Kansanradio, Vakiokuuntelija. Soitan tämmöisestä kun kuuntelin tänään eduskunnan tätä välikysymystuntia. Kahdeksatuntia kesti ministeri Lausosen puhe näistä työttömistä ynnä muista tämmöinen, että kun naapuri jää nukkumaan, kun toinen naapuri lähtee töihin, tuntuu ihan pöyristettävältä nämä hänen puheet ja sitten tämä, että miten paljon tämä nykyinen hallitus on saanut köyhyyttä Suomessa aika nimenomaan lapsköyhyyttä, että meillä -
- nälkäjonot kasvaa, leipäjonot kasvaa. Lapsille ei ole kohta ruokaa ostaa, vanhemmilla rahat lopussa. Tuntuu, että tämä hallitus ei ole käsitä tätä, että mitä ne ovat saaneet aikaiseksi Suomessa. Me olemme ihan kohta lamassa tosiaan ja ei tästä kyllä ihan heti nousta, että seuraavalla hallituksella on kyllä hirveä homma ja varmaan vielä sitten seuraavallakin. Hyvät jatkot ja keväänodotukset. Kiitos. Toivottavasti tämä tulee läpi. Kiitos. Hei.
No tieltä soitte lopi yksi ihan tämmöinen pitkäaikaista työtä ja tuota nyt on mulla hyvää omatunto kun tuota minä otin käyttöön tämän kokoumusministerin ohje. Minä kippistin kellon soimaan puol 7 kun normaalisti minä herreen 7 maissa. Nyt minä oon herreillä kun se tuo noapuri lähtöö tuossa osa aikatöihin tuonne markettiin. Kyllä se varmaan ne hommat ossoo kun se on korkeakoulutettu kaupalliselle alalle.
mutta sillä nyt ei saa olemaan se enempää töitä. Tässä nyt tämmöistä pikkutarina tai näistä työasioista. Eipä muuta.
-Huolestuttava tilanne, minkä hallitus on aiheuttanut tällä porvari-politiikalla. Kauppias odottaa asiakkaita, elikkä työttömiä ostamaan tavaraa, että kauppiaalla ei tulisi konkurssi.
-Ei, eläkeyhtiö hakee saatavia, mutta työttömät vaan nukkuu kotona eikä lähde ostamaan eikä pönkittämään porvari. Heh heh heh.
-Kuntelin taas eduskunnan kyselytunnin ja voisi pelkein sanoa, että ovat niin kaukana toisistaan vasemmisto ja oikeisto, että lähelle mennään jo osa juttuja ja sinnekään ei tarvitse mennä.
Nyt on vaikeat paikat ja pelastusta ei oikein näe. Jos ajatellaan, että ensi vuonna voisi olla sitten nämä vasemmisto siellä yrittämässä jotain, niin millään ei väi. Meiltähän puuttuvat osaajat, kuka rakentelee näitä työpaikkoja ja siihen riittyviä juttuja. Voisin sanoa, että nämä hurjimmat ja törkeimmät, varsinkin persujen edustajat, voisivat ainakin jättää pois seuraavasta hallituksesta. Siellä olis tota noin purralle oikein hyviä.
Tämmöisiä saksihommia, matonkuteita kutomaan tai leikkailemaan ja sitten se loppuporuka rupesi suojatyöpaikkoissa niitä mattoja loukuttamaan yhteen.
Tekoäly eduskuntaan. Tekoäly eduskuntaan millä tavoin? Kun sitä kerran joka paikkaan muuallekin kaupataan työpaikkoja ja ihmisiä sen takia väännetään, niin eduskunnassa olisikaan sitten varaa vähentää kohtaan tekoälyn käyttöä.
Joo, eli siis tekoälyllä korvattais kansanedustajia? Joo, ainakin siiteleminen ja toistensa päälle puhuminen ja toistensa syyttäminen ja huutelu niin loppuussa kun katsoo tuota kyselysuntiakin, niin tulee mieleensä kun Irvin Kuunman aikoinaan lauloi, että "tulkaa nähkää, kokekaa Suomeen suuri sirkus", niin tuntuu, että työpaikkoa.
Mutta siinä ei ole kysymys enää missään eduskunnassa, kun lapset juuri ihmettelee sitä, jotta kun ei me saada todella lailla koulutus huoltaan toisen vuoden päälle, niin kuinka nuo aikuiset ihmiset käyttäytyvät tuolla lailla?
Tästä on muuten tullut tänne useampikin viesti, jossa on ihmetelty ihan samaa, että onko siinä nyt tapahtunut hilja tai joku muutos, että se käytös on vaan mennyt yksinkertaisesti huonommaksi?
Vaikeita aikoja ollut ja aina on niin kuin sanotaan työllä ja ylittämisellä ja koulutuksella. Suomi on nostettu köyhyydestä silloin sävejälkeen tähän mitä se on ollut, mutta nyt tuntuu, että toinen yksijyttää yhtään, toinen syyttää toista, että tekoäly karsii sitten niin, jonka se katsoo se, että on sopiva sopimus.
Sopiva siellä työskentelemään. Minä toivotan. Hei, hyvää päivänjatkoa sunnuntaita kevään saapumista kanssa. Samo sulle. Kiitos paljon. Hei. Kiitos, moi. Meille saapunut viesti, jonka lähettänyt Henriikka, seitsemänkymmentäseitsemän V. Olen yksi kansalainen, joka on kyllästynyt opposition jatkuvaan räksytykseen ja saman asian kyselyyn monen edustajan suulla, vaikka kysymykseen on jo istunnon aikana selkeästi ja kansalaisen näkökulmasta ymmärrettävästi vastattu.
Muun muassa työttömyys ei ole yksin vastuussa olevan hallituksen syy, sillä sitä aiheuttavat monet asiat, mukaan lukien ay-liikkeiden akiteeraamat lakot, töiden siirtyminen robottien tehtäväksi, joita ei ole ryhdytty verottamaan sekä ne firmat, jotka tuovat ulkomaisia työntekijöitä. Ihmettelen Suomen käytäntöä. Kun kilpailutetaan, niin miksi yhdeksi ehdoksi ei vaadita, että tarjouksen hyväksyttävyyteen vaikuttaa, että ensisijaisesti työllistetään Suomeen?.
Ja jos näin ei tule tapahtumaan, tulee sanktio. Henriikka77v laittaa terveiset viestinsä loppuun. Eli siis ihmetellä täytyy, kun samoja asioita kysytään yhä uudestaan ja uudestaan. Ihmettelyä välillä jaan huutomerkein aiheuttaa myös seuraavat aiheet.
Lepuret paistaa leipiään. Muutaako korkeintaan jälkiuunileipiään? Ja sekin on vanhemmalla päivänä ja suolistavaikeuksissa olevalle huisliipää on vähän liian huono. Aikoinaan oli taurasta jälkiuunileipä ja sekin jo lopetettiin.
Ei löydy enää jälkiuunileipää kun ruisi?. Ei löydy enää. Ainakaan Keravalta en ole löytänyt monien kuukauteen. Sitä vielä pystyi syömään, mutta toiset Kauraleivät on ihan täyttä paikinaa. Ihan kuin olisin vähän aikaa sitten kaupassa nähnyt Kauraa jälkiuunileipää?.
En minä ainakaan Keravalla ole nähnyt pissiin tämän vuoden puolella. Sitähän pitää siellä nykästää henkilökuunnan hihasta?. Olen olenkoittanut. Ei me osaa sanoa piljat mitään ja yleensä leivänpaistot ei saa jäädä raaks. Esimerkiksi Karjalan piirakakkonen jätetään puoli raaks niin ei ole sen makuisia kuin ei pitäisi olla.
Vaimoni vei ensimmäisen kerran Minijana ollessa hanoppille ja seuraavana aamuna ne paistoi piirakoita. Se hyvä tapa minkä mummoni ja äitini ovat tehittäneet meni Minijalle, mutta kun hän kuoli niin ei ole saanut kunnon piirakkaa eikä kunnon leippatouhuakaan.
Syönkö minäkin siis tällä hetkellä huonolaatuisia karjalan piirakoita?. Ilmeisesti!. No niin. Kiitos. Kiitos. Moi!. Täällä Maija Liisat ihmettelee huono selkeästi. Avaruusaluuksia on keksitty ja käyty kuun pinnalla, mutta Rikka Lapio ja Harja yhdistelmässä Rikka Lapion varsi katkeaa ja jo muutaman käytön jälkeen minulla on.
Olen kolme irronnutta vartta. Siistä ei avaruusalusta vaan varsin joka pysyy Rikka Lapiossa kiinni kun sitä käytetään. Jään odottelemaan tätä ihmettä että saisin roskat lattialta ylös. Kiitos. Hei!.
kuin bensaa. Minun käsittääkseni sen takia tasoittaakseni tätä eroa oli tämä käyttövoiman vero, joka pitää maksaa dieselistä. Mutta nyt onkin käynyt niin päin, että diesel on paljon kalliimpaa kuin bensiini. Millä ihmeellä nyt perustellaan tätä käyttövoiman veroa tälle dieselille? Minusta se pitäisi olla bensiinille, jos nyt jossakin pitäisi olla se käyttövoiman vero. Heippa.
Minä olen käynyt tässä terveyskeskuksessa paikallisessa ja keskussairaalan kirjan polilla ja nämä nuoret lääkärit koko ajan näpläävät konetta, mutta ne eivät kuuntele, vaikka katokka potilasta, että minä olen tätä ihmetellyt ja sanoinkin sillä kirurgian poliisin, että sinä koko ajan näpläisit tätä konetta, että se vastaanottoaika menee siihen koneen näpläämiseen. Ja sitten se, että vain yksi asia kerralla. Sitten jos hupean sanomaan, että minulla on vaikka olkapääkippeni, tilaa uusi aika, sanotaan vaan tämmöistä.
Hyvin edellistä yhteiskunnan väärinkäyttö. Kiitos. Hei.
Oikeustohallituksemme taas kärvistelee talouspolitiikan kysymyksissä, kerralle ja kaarrelle vastauksia. Ei hyvältä näytää joko yksityistötään tai sitten yhtiötetään erilaisia juttuja. Nyt oli uutisissakin juttu, tossa oli tämä vesikorotuksia tulossa, koska luovat, että vesi on liian halpaa Suomessa suomalaisille. Voi hyvää estäisi. Mediassani on soviteltuna demareille noita.
Ministeri viittaa sitten, että saan nähdä sitten mitä Lindtman ja kumppaneet sitten kehittää, jos näin vaan valtaa pääsevät. Ja miksipä ei niin, että mitä myydä ja kelle, että hyvää kesää ja vappua. Morjes!
Päivää Ylivieskasta. Päivää Ylivieskaan. Mitä kuuluu? Eduskunnan kuntakoon antoi luottamusta hallitukselle, niin sitä äänestys.
Minä ihmettelenkö, niin noin kahdeksankymmentä oli puolesta ja neljäkymmentä vastaan ja neljäkymmentäkahdeksan kansanedustajaa poissa. Mitä se tarkoittaa? Eiköhän ne poistu sieltä kesken kauan. Onko niillä joku nappi, jonka ne painaa, että olet poissa? Tärkeä äänestys on, että voidaan painaa vain nappia, että olet poissa.
Olisiko se kiva kuulla sitten heiltä, että minkä takia he olivat poissa? Mitkä ovat ne syyt? Siihen haluaisin kyllä vastausta vain etäjässä ajaa. Ei tämä enempää hyvää joulun odotusta. Kiitos Samoen. Kiitos Samoen. Jo hei. Moi.
Pesemään suu saippualla. Radio Suomen musiikkitoimittajat voisivat mennä kaikki pesemään suunsa saippualla, sillä joka käänteessä tulee viisuja, jotka ovat saatanoita ja helvettejä pullollaan. Minäkin maksan pakollista yleveroa ja vaadin kitkettäväksi soittolistoilta nuo kappalet. Eivät kuulu sivistyneeseen yleiskieleen terveisin Anja, eli siis ei pelkästään kiroilijalle saippua suuhun, vaan myös hänelle joka sen mahdollistaa.
Televisiolla ja radiolla me jatkamme. Kansanradio. - Kuule täällä on naisihminen täältä etelä Suomesta. Hei. - Etelä Suomessa minäkin tällä hetkellä. Tervehdys. - Kuule kun minä paljon olen näkorajoitteinen niin kuuntelen hyvin tarkoin mitä tulee radiosta ja televisiosta. Ja vaikka siellä televisiossakin esimerkiksi joku, no yleensä se on naisihminen joka
Se puhuu kyllä asiaa, mutta hän puhuu sen niin nopeasti tykittämällä, että suoraan sanoen se kuulostaa kälätykseltä.
Ja sitten kun mä ajattelen sitä, että mitä hän sanoi, niin mä en saanut selvä, että mitä hän sanoi. Ja tää on hyvin yleistä nuorten naisten keskuudessa ja yleensä naisten, niin mihin heillä on kiire kuolemaanko?
Kyllä sinne on vielä aikaa, että kannattaisi hiukan hiljentää. Mutta kaikin puolin naurinkoista ja ilosta sunnunta, että minäkin lähden tästä ulkoilemaan. Kiitos ja hei.
Vähän yli yksi, niin on kuvitellut, että se on yö, vaikka kello on todellisuudessa kolmetoista nolla viisi. Niin opetelkaa sanomaan siellä se kellon aika niin kuin se on, joten se siitä sitten. Täällä yksi vihainen kuunteli ja nyt moi.
Nykyisten jälkeen tulee semmoinen ilmoitus, mitä luulee, että se vaan jatkaa uutisia. Kerrostolo on romahtanut Helsingissä ja niin edelleen ja ihmisiä on kuollut. Ja tuntuu ensin ihan, että hyvännen aika. Miksei tota sanottu heti uutisten aluksi? Sitten vasta hoksaan, että hei, tää onkin mainos. Kuinka moni mummo on pelastunut? Minä ainakin. Hei.
Hei, joo Vilho täällä. Nyt se selvisemmiksi tulee tuota näitä Suomen huutokauppakeisaria ja aina vain moneen kymmenen vuoden takaa tulee uusintoja. No kun Espanjassa on Rakkauden saari, siellä kaksi kuukautta juuri nuorisoporukka juuri ja ryppää. Teevellat maksaa nekin kato. Voi helvetin johtaja. Nyt semmoinen johtokunnat helvettiin täältä.
Rakkauden saari kyllä se nyt loppuu se Rakkauden saari. Altiolle saarelle tei jouluttaa.
Kevät kun saapuu niin sehän tarkoittaa että ainakin kaksi asiaa tapahtuu. Jääkiekkoliiga se huipentuu
finaalisarjaan ja ihminen kaivaa pyörän esiin kellarista. Tullut meille tällainen viesti jossa ilmoitetaan että kyllä Kaakonkulmalla ja Tamperella ollaan oltu kateellisia helsinkiläisille, turkulaisille ja
koululaisille, sillä siellä ei tarvitse päivittäin kuunnella lätkäotteluiden päivityksiä ja jossittelua. Toisessa WhatsAppiin saapuneessa viestissä puolestaan kutsutaan hesalaisia kiittämättömiksi, kun saivat uuden hienon Kruunuvuoren sillan ja nyt sitten viingutaan muutaman sentin muuta tietä alemmista liikuntasaumoista. Ei sinne kenenkään ole pakko mennä, muuallakin voi pyöräillä uskomatonta valittamista. Ja sitten paluu menneisyyteen eli minkälainen
reaktiota herättäneet menneiden jaksojen puhelut. - Moikka. Viime sunnuntain Kansanradiossa oli eräällä rouvalla useita ehotuksia, mitä koulussa pitäisi opettaa meidän lapsille ja nuorille. Oli muun muassa vuorovaikutustaitoja käyttäytymistä, terveyskasvatusta, siivousta, ruuanlaittoa, mitä toivottiin opetettavan. Itse työskentelen
yläkoulun erityisluokaopettajana ja mä oon ehkä vähän kyllästänyt siihen, että jatkuvasti mediassa sanotaan, mitä koulussa pitäisi tehdä ja opettaa. Valtakunnallinen opetussuunnitelmahan on esimerkiksi netissä kaikkien nähtävillä. En tiedä löytyisikö vaikka kirjastoista, jos se on nettiä käytössä. Ja sittähän niihin on niitä paikallisia tarkennuksia, jotka myös on sitten jokaisessa kunnassa ja kaupungissa -
saatavilla ja nähtävillä. Ja vuorovaikutustaitoja ja käyttäytymistähän meillä on ihan joka päivä koulussa itselläni ainakin tunnetaitoja, opetetaan erikseenkin. Terveyskasvatusta on terveystiedon tunneilla, liikuntatunneilla. Rouva toivoisi myös enemmän näitä liikuntatunteja, niin pidennetäänkö me sitten koulupäiviä vai mitä me sitten opetettaisiin vähemmän. Nämä ovat ihan tämmöisiä aika isoja päätöksiä. Ja kotitaloudessa on sitten siivousta -
ruuanlaittoa. Herää mulle myös tietenkin opettajana kysymys, että mitä sit kotona opetetaan, että jos ihan koulussa pitää oman huoneen siivouksesta lähtien asiat opettaa, niin voisko siellä kotonakin sit jotain huoltajien kanssa harjoitella, että kuitenkin lapset on koulussa semmosen noin ehkä kuusi tuntia päivässä, että suurimmassa ajassa he kuitenkin on sit kotonsa.
Tää on ensimmäinen ihminen, joka otan tuohon murteeseen kantaa. No joo kun mä ihmettelen tähän ensimmäinen ihminen. Mä oon nyt jo reilusti yli kahdeksankymppinen ja mie haastan karjoamaan murretta ja se on ihan hauskaa ja mä en oo missään. Mä käyn monissa kerhoissa ja tapahtumissa ja siellä on ihan hauskaa jos joku osaa jotain murretta. Niin tää on ensimmäinen ihminen, joka suhtautuu näin kielteisesti murteeseen, joka soitti sinne ja mä ajattelin, että jotenkin mieltäisiin sinne. Ja niin se on.
Mä ajattelin iteksäni, että onko täs nyt tämmönen joku psykologinen juttu, että hän on pettynyt murteeseen ja puhuu vaan ihmiseen vai mistä voi olla kysymys? Ois hauskausias joskus perustellis vähän tarkemmin. Niin jos hän rupeaa huutamaan, että tämä asia on tyhmä, niin kertois sitten, että minkä takia se asia on tyhmä eikä vaan ilmoita kyllä. Ois ihan mielenkiintoista tietää, että mistä tämmönen johtuu. Mä voin kertoa tässä sen pitkä juttu aika hauskan kun mennään tänne.
naimisiin mun miehen kanssa. Hän, mä oon karjalainen ja hää on savolainen. Ja mentiin mun kotiisilla aika ensimmäisiä kertoja ja siellä oli sit saunan lämpiämässä ja mummo sano että jospä Eino nyt menis satsamaan niitä juskia ja sit ettei tuu vinkaa. En tiedä ymmärrätkö sinäkäänä sä. Niin no sitten tota mun mies kuiskas mulle että mitä mun pitää tehdä? No juskaan tää pelti mikä on siellä ja sit ee tuo vinkka.
häkää, mutta mä sitä miettä, joka soitti, että jos hän ei ymmärrä jotain sanaa, niin sehän on ihan hauskaa, että kysyy sitten, että mitä se merkitsee.
- Niin, ehkä hän ei ole ymmärtänyt jotain sanaa ja nyt se sitten tulee kiukkuna ulos jostain syystä.
- Joo, joku kiukku siinä nyt oli, mut mä häämästän hirveesti, kun viljensä kannustetaan puhumaan murteita ja nähän nyt on täällä ollut viikapäivät ennen tätä meidän äidinkieltä ihan.
- Joo, ja siis se alueelliset erot kielessä, niin se on vaan rikkaus ja se on mielenkiintoista ja sitä on hauskaa kuunnella.
- Ja se elävöittää puhetta, että mä olin tosi ihmeessäni, mutta tämmöinen oli minun kannanotto tähän.
- Hei, hyvä juttu kun soitit tänne. - Joo, kiitos. Hei hei. - Päivän jatkot, moi. - Moi, moi.
- Siellä joku mies kyseli, että pitääkö liikennevaloissa pitää turvaväliä. Itsellä kävi muutama vuosi ja kaveri niin, että oli liikennevaloissa ja kaksi autoa oli edessä ja joku nainen, kuuta, seitsemää, kympi, suoraa oman autoni peräänpäähän. Kaikki nämä autot meni lunastukseen, eli itse tulen pitämään jatkossakin turvaväliä liikennevaloissa. Hei.
Tästä on jo jonkin aikaa, kun soitin Kansanradioon ja epäili sitä, että ei mene kauan, kun Amerikan rumpu juistaa itsensä pyhimykseksi. Ja nyt se on tapahtunut. Terveisin kansalainen.
Rouva Uudeltamaalta. Kuuntelin sunnuntaina Kansanradioon ja järkytyin. Minusta ei tällaisia puheluja, kun joku Kalevi soitti ja haukkui Suomen itsenäisyyttä, ihmisiä ja nimitteli erittäin pahasti ja kyseenalaisti Baltian ja Ukrainan itsenäisyydelle. Minusta toimittaja, joka tämän laski ulos, -
verkkoon olisi syytä saada huomautus. Olen todella pahoillani, että Suomen kansan yleisradiossa on tällaisia puheluja. Kiitos. Kysytään, että miten tuollainen mielipide voi päästä lähetykseen? Se johtuu siitä, että Kansanradiossa sana on vapaa. Täällä kuullaan kansalaisten mielipiteitä. Oli niiden kanssa ihan kaikki samaa mieltä tai ei kukaan. Joskus kun kuulee sellaisen mielipiteet, -
joka saa pudistelemaan päätään niin ehkä siinä voi olla sellainen hyvä puoli että sitten ainakin on tietoinen että millä eri tavoin ympärillä olevat ihmiset tai saman maan kansalaiset ajattelevat. Ja kysymyksen makuun kun päästiin niin lisää kysymyksiä.
että niillä on vaikea kulkea maastossa esimerkiksi metsäpaluille ei pääse jos niissä olisi noin kaksikymmentäviisi senttimetriä halkasialtaan pyörät ja noin kolme senttiin leveät niillä pystyisi paremmin talvelakin sohjossa kulkemaan.
kiinni että suunniteltu on varmaan kuljettimaan vaan asfalttipoluilla tai teillä. - Niin mutta isommat renkaat niin sitten pääsee myös metsäpaluille. - Kyllä talvella kun on sohjoa ja tommoista ei niin niillä pääsee tökki eteenpäin. Tässä on noin kolme senttiin leveät renkaat ja noin kaksikymmentäviisi senttiin halkasia.
Vois vähän paremmin päästä eteenpäin. Kukahan nyt niitä rullaattoreita Suomessa valmistaa että saas Suomen olosuhteisiin koska täällä on talvikelit ja metsä ja polkuja. No kiitoksia. - Kiitos paljon kun soitit. - Kiitos hei. - Päivänjatkut moi. - Olen oikein aimo poika tieltä heinämeteltä ja tuota haluaisin tietää paljon kun tuo.
Muankamaran valaiseminen maksaa näinä vaikeina aikoina kun tuota nykyään noissa teknikävehkeissä on tehokkaat valolaitteet ja jos joku liikkuu jalakasin niin tuolloin on valolaitteita otsa-lamppua ja muuta sähkölamppua käytettäväksi jotta tuntuu ihmeelle kun raha on puhuttu niin raha on niin vähissä ja kuitenkin tuota muankamarvoa pitää valaista niin paljon.
- Tuolla on liikenteessä ja täällä liikepaikoilla ennen kaikkea. Ei pitäisi olla muutokset.
- Tiedonhaluinen kansalainen soittelee. Tässä iltapuhteella tuli kauheasti mieleen tämmöinen asia niin kuin sopeutumiseläke.
Paljonko se on kuussa tai maassa? Voisiko sitä hakea Kelalta tai Melalta? Kaikki ihmiset samaa arvoisiksi ja heille sopeutumiseläke. Kiitos.
- Seuraa numeroa ja osoitetta eli siis Kansanradion yhteystiedot. Meidän WhatsApp-numer on 044 5515464. Sähköpostit osoitteeseen kansan.radio.yli.fi.
Perinteinen posti osoitteeseen kansan.radio pl 7 9 00024 Yleisradio. Automaattinen vastaaja joka lähetyksen jälkeen kolmen tunnin ajan on ihmisvastaja. Sen numero puolestaan 0800 15464. Ja tähän loppuun me kuullaan vielä pari tavalla tai toisella ajankohtaan liittyvää puheen vuoroa.
Lasse Olkinuora kiittää saapuneista kommenteista ja kiitos kun kuuntelit. Vappu se on muuten tässä välissä ennen kuin seuraavan kerran kuullaan joten minä toivotan jo tässä vaiheessa oikein onnistuneet vaput. Itsehän aion pitää perinteitä yllä eli siis syön yhden tippaleivän vappuna ja sitten ääneen pohdin että miksiköhän minä aina vappuna syön yhden tippaleivän kun minä en oikeastaan pidä tippaleivistä. Mutta perinteistä en luova. Hyvää päivänjatkoa. Voi hyvin.
Hei kansanradio. Tässä kevättuulahduksia. Seksia seitsemänkymmentävuotiaille. Seksi on ihanaa kun muistaa rakastella. Oikein raju rakastelu voimaannuttaa. Seitsemänkymppisille pitäisi julkaista oma seksiopas. Mistä seitsemänkymmentävuotias voisi löytää itselleen sopivaa seksiselraa? Oikein hyvä kysymys. Miten seitsemänkymppinen voisi herättää?.
Kokemusasiantuntijana voin sanoa. Seitsemänkymppisten seksi on yhtä kiihkeää kuin nuorempien seksi. Hyvää seksi kevättä kaikille seitsemänkymppisille. Muistakaa rakastella. Heippa.
Täälläpä on pohjoissavosta marjamuori kun huolestuneena on tähän nykypäivän tilanteeseen. Niin minä tuossa kun Onkive-laineen liplatusta kahtelin niin ajattelin että se on kyllä aika hyvä laulu. Se lasten laulu että jos me täällä haluat männän nyt niin Takula yllätyt. Siihen vielä tämä rimsun jälkeen.
Joku tekisi uudet sanat ja eipä tänä päivänä uskalla tuonne mehtään männä kun ei tiedä minkälainen mörrimöykky siellä puun takana oikein vahtoo. Ja se minua vähän huolestuttaa että jos marjamuori lentää möppiset kanssa ilmaan ihan tuusan nuskaksi niin kuka sen korvoo kun vakuutusyhtiöt ovat sanoneet että eivät korvoo mitään?.
mikä sovasta aiheutuu. Että nuo jälkipolvet, jotka jäävät tuonne rannalle ruikuttamaan, niin olisikohan se niin, että niihin pitää pyytää sitten tuolta puolustusvoimaa budjetista korvaaksia. Ja minäpä jatkan tässä nyt kahtelemaan on kiveen lainneen liplatusta. Se rauhoittaa niin hyvin paremmin kuin -
orponsanat. Kiitoksia.